[Musique]
et ce soir il ya une personne qui a
voulu déclarer son amour à quelqu'un sur
ce plateau 1 et oui est ce qu'on peut
voir cette personne
s'il vous plaît cette personne on va la
découvrir lé ton ombre chinoise
jean lucas jackson en nombre aux
chinoises c'est farrell il vient pour et
nohra
kaka qui venait de déclarer son amour à
quelqu'un sur le plateau alors là on
rigole mais je vous dis dans un an ce
taux
je pense que ça va être plus compliqué
est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un dans le public
qui pourront se reconnaître cette
personne ce que quelqu'un pour te
reconnaître cette personne dans comme sa
personne on va donner à la personne de
parler de dire une petite phrase allez-y
ça fait 25 ans que je connais la
personne en question
ça fait 25 ans qu'il connaît la personne
en question n'a pas pris un peu plus de
maîtrise en langues
est ce que quelqu'un qui reconnaît cette
personne dans le public non autour de la
table non personne
il va y va reparler
on vous écoute j'ai préparé un petit
message pour la personne du boulot lit
ça fait plus de vingt cinq ans que l'on
se connaît que l'on se côtoie et que
l'on s'apprivoise les années ont passé
et nous nous sommes un peu éloigné mais
si j'ai sur mon compte du long gardoise
le lien qui nous unit mais c'est jamais
briser et si les longs discours ne sont
pas mon fort ma présence ce soir
et ces mots qui viennent du coeur
devrait te prouver sans grands efforts
que j'ai été et reste ton plus grands
admirateurs
alors moi il va me faire chier rires
est-ce que quelqu'un reconnaisse cette
personne s'est mis alors moi y'a un truc
bizarre si toi non non il ya un truc
bizarre parce que je sais et toi je sais
pas pourquoi mais j'ai des battements de
coeur oui et c'est pas un mec déjà ça
c'est sûr fatou par un amant en tout cas
non non mon sac et et et qu'antisémite
profil
oui il peut se remettre de profits ils
passeront peut remettre prévoit remettre
de profil
monsieur mais c'est mon fils pensez que
c'est votre fils il s'appelle comment
votre fils il s'appelle guillaume est ce
que vous appelez guillaume oui
[Applaudissements]
dommage
les hommes eux
m
[Applaudissements]
du lot
s'il vous plaît guillaume à petit
message pour isabelle mais venez l'aller
chez guillaume et moins qu'il ait fait m
hyper millau et guillaume vous avez un
message pour votre maman qu'on aime fort
utilisables tels toulouse
ça paraît tellement c'est pour toi je le
fais ben écoute je sais depuis surtout
le justement c on se voit plus trop trop
souvent du coup c c'est l'occasion ou
jamais quand j'étais plaît par l'équipe
m'a appelé hier c'était un peu compliqué
mais du coup j'ai eu les occasions pour
pour venir te voir parce que je déteste
les médias celle inverse de mathieu
quand je laime nos césars il s'emmerder
comme un rat mort il s'est endormi à
table et tout est donc il déteste les
médias il regarde là ils regardent
l'émission 3 ce que je dis sur lui
verser un message il vous aime bien ça
ne grossissait bonne touche sur tous
vraiment beaucoup de remous y aura vécu
la chose à vous dire c'est vrai que
c'est il nous a donc se regardent pas
nazi tout simplement je t'aime je cours
merci
merci des eaux
ça y est après ça c'est parce que tu me
parle souvent lui tu me dis tu vois pas
et bat guillaume mitaine fort et voulait
que dire ce soir
merci mais comme ça merci merci merci
guillaume tabard est avec nous la saison
[Applaudissements]